bene di ragazzi e benvenute questo
nuovissimo video come sempre oggi sul
rocchetto né nazionale sono con lo
stesso nazionale perché sono stati
squadra man si gioca più e quindi
proveremo a raggiungere il ormai lo
diciamo da 62 video ma fa niente
il rank champion abbiamo a del valais
chissenefrega dei nomi gol
l'esitazione nome sì sì l'altro e pino
c'è scritto quello pb da software gli
amici allora attenzione si no ragazza
doveva fare assumere andavano solenne da
una dopo c'erano già addosso su
surrender
io ho tolto il turbo attenzione questo
tenterà di spingerla lì ma io per
accettarla no perché l'ha messa dentro
bravo bravissimo anzi mammamia bravo
cos'è un preso finalmente una sfilata di
quelle incredibili che io non vedo
neanche nelle sport però col no ok prova
a ripartire se riusciamo a smettere la
butto dentro io ragazzina che tanto lo
vedo che ma ero nero dritto va bene per
i turbo se vuoi prendere veramente ai ha
ironizzato dissociando lo so ragazzi non
guardate questo video va fra uscite da
questa pagina guardate qualcosa da
vedere cosa sta facendo tecniche surya
by step che il video di stato è uscito
viber scappa mamma mia dove si è messo
bene perché non sono in grado di fare un
cross polo
avevo preso una panchina no perché
dopotutto giro va bene attaccato e un po
di più non si è capito niente però cosa
parlava fare poco apprezzato escludermi
l'ho saltato
mamma mia l'ho vista tutta la scena ci
sono che minuto rai2 papanimico anche
voi
ti lascio si issa 20mo rito tantissimo
io posso tirare sì sì magari un'altra
volta però manca 30 c cosmari nessuno ha
fatto un gol va bene attenzione
puoi tirare tumore no no no io ho
verissimo adesso valore
ok ti ho aspettato disistima
ma è vero che la porta centro
cominciavano attenzione per questa sera
mamma mia che è ripartito 6 non è vero
che bella 60000 atroci sulle minuti
arresto via fa partita interminabile
no non è vero mille tranquilla adesso sì
che è vero
lascia solo me era vero ti prego parola
si sicuro a segno
hai visto e buona buona buona e mano
colpa quasi pronto
non so non credo mi dispiace ma sono due
giorni bisogna vincerla la carica per
questo stesso in questa vittoria che
stai per vedere occhio che le gol ma poi
l'hotel è domandato c con il goloso
era la partita più lunga del pianeta di
rocket league
dieci minuti per fare un gol abbiamo
avrei fatto due partite in una 2 madonna
possibile due parti c'è bagarre per la
partita poi se si pensa che colpisce
continua ragazzi per questa non so come
descriverlo processi di 7 litri 7 allora
tensione è non è vero mi ha fregato
fortissimo
l'ho tolto sì però penso quello la tira
ma madonna perché deve essere sempre
quelli mm fregarmi nella vita perché
perché volta bordo ti prego ti prego ma
magari ma la sfiga dove ma perché
attenzione un bellissimo no lascia che
ti voglio
ma la sbaglio 100 100 e invece strano
perché si è cagato in genere le facce ha
fatto delle robe che non ho capito
niente però va bene bravo ok di
dribbling bravissimo mamma mia come se è
guardando lo merita perché farli ei no
che cosa perché ragazzi ragazzi non
lontano mi disse mi dissocio dal del mio
gaming per 20 ok ma andiamo a messa in
modo un po strano non l'ho messa ei
bravissimo propri va bene ma mi dissocio
vista di andare da solo paglia gialle
non tagliare ciò che frena e si si
proprio immobile nel centro per
l'attenzione con se penso che vincerà
mai ho tolto lui
vabbè è un'idea meno male meno male che
avevo fatto l'ha pagato alta alta alta
occhio quello miracolo dire a quello
tira via va bene ma e papà ma anche
parti si nono turno però cavolo provato
a dire loro che vanno porno tolto
nessuno è un bel passaggio per ma oramai
bel tiro si però non so non potevo fare
altro che questo bravo allora ma perché
perché non ho saltato prima era gol
fatto ma c'era golf a brava messa anche
quando i giocatori fps te lo assicuro lo
facevo a casa mia io facevo un cane ma
sembra un claim per quanto gioco qua ma
è vero valeria ma supplementari che
questa questa mamma mia che partita
ideali ma che la chiamano in modo più
stupido metto la faccia
sì io sono un rischio qua aspetta bello
bellissimo ma dopo l'altro 68 è a stare
senza il tocco o che la mitica fatto
cosa insegna anche un cane è però bravo
bello bello breve non va bene ma che
tocco di uscito poco succede lì mi sono
posto ti prego no oggi
non ci credo vada da manuale è stata
bravissima che cavolo ma è stato bravo
ragazzi questo avrà bisogno di giudei
con lo stesso né spero che sia piaciuto
ma se non si fa perché sono anormali
bikini scusa purtroppo perché con questo
sei tappe non ho è mio pc del solito 15
a quello temporaneo che è un po meno
prestante quindi su roche tempo si sente
perché ha un po di input lag di un po di
cose che mi faccio un po più schifo del
solito prova per noi vi sia piaciuto
l'asi traiano non mi piace anche le
socie che non identici se come si chiede
ma come sempre ci diamo al prossimo
video
[Musica]